intéressons-nous au cas de Groot mais
non merci Romain groot c'est un
extraterrestre végétal à forme humaine
et bien notre brave gardien de la
galaxie pourrait bien être atteint
d'épidermodysplasie vérusiforme qu'on
appelle aussi la maladie de l'homme
arbre c'est une maladie orpheline
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est très rare on en
a répertorié 200 cas dans le monde mais
ceux d'Abul bajandar et DD cososvara ont
été très médiatisés une multitude de
verrues se développe sur les mains les
pieds le visage le thorax sans
traitement et dans les cas extrêmes les
lésions peuvent proliférer envahir les
membres jus à leur donner un aspect
d'écorse d'où le nom de la maladie qui
se soigne malheureusement très mal les
traitements permettent de ralentir
l'évolution des lésions ou de retirer
les plus grosses mais on ne sait pas
stopper complètement leur progression